un début d'année difficile un début
d'année dans l'incertitude après une
année 2010 9 exceptionnelle avec nous le
stratège vincent delisle pour en parler
ce soir bonsoir
dans son antre soirée bonne année à vous
et un également je vous en souhaite une
aussi bonne que 2010 9 2019 a été une
année exceptionnelle et une année hors
norme en faire non non non
quand on regarde la performance de tous
les actifs on parle surtout des marchés
boursiers qui ont une année de rendement
très très généreux mais la presque
totalité des actifs tout ce qu'on a en
portefeuille obligations fonds mutuels
actions ont connu une année très très
très forte qu'on n'a pas vu depuis
trente ou quarante ans voir autant de
classes d'actifs augmenté de la sorte
regardons tout de suite les chiffres de
quelques-uns de ses actifs de ces
indices indices s&p 500 new york 31 %
lundi ce mondial 25% les tsx à toronto
avant les dividendes 19% leurs dix huit
différents types d'obligations sept à
quatorze les ressources 5 les
obligations américaines 2 pour ça oui
alors ce qui saute aux yeux si secteur
des verts alors 2019
tous les actifs ont grimpé on parle de
rendement qui son action hors norme je
le répète
historiquement la performance historique
lors des cent dernières années du s&p
500 ont pas le rendement annuel environ
7%
donc quand on fait du 31 % c'est cet
exceptionnel
les prix de l'or qui grimpe de 18 % le
pétrole aussi l'an dernier qui a grimpé
de 15 20 % donc les obligations qui
montrent le prix dollar le prix du
pétrole les actions alors c était très
très généreux comme rama comment vous
l'expliquez enfin qu'il ya deux raisons
la principale raison les dérives et y
est presque rien
au début de l'année 2019 on appréhende
et on pensait que les banques centrales
allaient grimper leurs taux d'intérêt
notamment la réserve fédérale américaine
et celle inverse qui s'est produit alors
en 2019 la banque centrale américaine a
baissé ses taux à trois reprises dans la
dernière moitié de 2010 9 on a
répertorié 50 baisse de taux ça te
regarde toutes les banques centrales
dans le monde
alors ce qui est debout
coup les marchés boursiers c'est lorsque
les taux d'intérêt baissent donc le
marché dopés aux baisses de taux mais
dopé il y avait crainte la guerre
commerciale des etats unis la chine
faisait rage rien on n'a pas encore et
les banques centrales de façon
préventive ont baissé les taux d'intérêt
donc la forte baisse des taux d'intérêt
a eu un effet très positif surtout les
classes d'actifs sur tous les marchés
boursiers l'autre facteur qui est arrivé
un peu plus tard en 2019
l'apaisement et je me l'an passé le mot
apaisement des tensions commerciales
entre la chine et les états unis
on n'a pas fini d'avoir des certitudes
de ce côté là mais on va signer la phase
1 de l'entente qui a été annoncé avant
noël alors ces deux facteurs les taux
d'intérêt qui ont baissé beaucoup au fn
un soulagement pour les investisseurs et
vers la fin d'année 2010 9 l'espoir que
kylie n est qu elle me hante les états
unis la chine a un effet positif et tout
cela a un effet sur le marché canadien
quand on voit le tsx autour de 20%
il est alimenté aussi par ça absolument
quand on regarde la bourse canadienne la
bourse canadienne a une particularité il
ya beaucoup de sites pétroliers
au canada on le sait l'un des pires
secteur l'an dernier et un secteur du
pétrole à leur nudité le des difficultés
du secteur de l'énergie du pétrole et du
gaz l'an dernier le tsx ret programme a
eu un rendement aussi aux environs de 25
30% tout comme la bourse américaine bond
intéressant donc après une année
exceptionnelle on va regarder maintenant
surtout pour 2020 ce qui va se passer
vous avez identifié trois choses à
regarder la première chose les taux
d'intérêt les taux d'intérêt ça a été
déterminant en 2019 seul est toujours
déterminant c'est déterminable parce que
ce qu'on a eu en 2009 ces deux fortes
baisses de taux d'intérêt on semble
avoir atteint un creux d'un pour
l'économie mondiale à l'automne 2010 9h
2019 s'est faite sur le ton de la
décélération économique si une reprise
économique en 2020 en carton baisse les
taux absolument ça aide l'économie
mais pendant qu'on va voir les faits
inverse au niveau des taux d'intérêt les
taux d'intérêt qui augmenterait
légèrement ça pourrait avoir un impact
négatif sur certaines classes d'actifs
donc si les taux augmentent et que le
bilan économique est meilleure en 2020
tous les classes d'actifs sur votre
tableau ne seront pas ouvertes l'année
prochaine on est mais cela dit ça veut
pas dire que les banques centrales vont
augmenter les banques centrales
devraient rester sur les lignes de côté
il reste peut-être je parlais tout à
l'heure de 50 baisses de taux
répertoriées dans le monde en deuxième
moitié 2010 9 il en reste peut-être
quelques-unes mais ce qui risque
d'arriver c'est que les dos des
échéances plus long terme et obligations
des gouvernements échéance 5 ans 10 ans
ceci est le meilleur baromètre de
l'appétit pour le risque si c'est aulas
remonte et ils réagissent très
rapidement mais ça va avoir un effet
négatif sur certaines classes d'actifs
la politique américaine bien sûr c'est
une année d'élection l'élection
présidentielle et le 3 novembre
ça va jouer beaucoup sur 2020 absolument
alors tout où la politique est politique
américain va avoir 1 et rennaise un
impact important 2020 salué en 2019
monsieur treiber se faire réélire il a
besoin d'une économie qui va bien on
commence années 2020 avec des tensions
une guerre une vraie guerre semble-t-il
risque de guerre entre l'iran et les
etats-unis 1-1 on a tous ceux dont on a
parlé des derniers mois c'était la
guerre commerciale et un effet négatif
sur l'économie aura peut-être que le
focus bret au moyen-orient pour les
américains ah qu'elle me apaisement avec
la chine mais il faudra tenir pour
compte que monsieur trump veut se faire
réélire il aura besoin d'une économie
qui accélère parce que l'an dernier les
raids de croissance et que l'américaine
avait décéléré aux environs de 2%
monsieur cheveux du 3%
c'est ce qu'il avait promis et on
surveille l'évolution du dollar
américain
absolument on parle beaucoup de tension
de valeur refuge des certitudes depuis
quelques jours ce qui est à remarquer
c'est que vers la fin 2010 9 dollars
américains a commencé à faiblir
ce qui nous inquiète moins à court terme
même si le prix de l'or augmente c'est
le fait que le refuge ne se fait pas
dans les devises non plus de dollars
américains qui bails cela pourrait
amener indifférente échiquier de
leadership en 2020 quand le dollar
américain baisse est elle seulement bien
mieux pour le prix des ressources c'est
absolument mieux pour les indices des
pays émergents et une et dix comme le
canada ferait mieux que la bourse
américaine si dollar américain se
réplique est d'ailleurs un dollar
canadien monte à 65 cents américains
dollar canadien fait bientôt quelques
temps vincent delisle merci beaucoup je
vous en prie